We all know how easy it is to be completely mesmerized
By a new crush and when you're falling for someone it can seem like nothing else really matters
But the sad truth is that some crushes can be unhealthy and that's something everyone needs to watch out for
Can you think of a time when you had an unhealthy crush?
You might even be in the midst of an unhealthy crush right now without actually realizing it
but have no fear because we're about to tell you all about which crushes we think can be potentially unhealthy and
What to look out for one rushing on someone who's already in a relationship?
Let's get the obvious stuff out of the way first
Yes crushing on someone who's in a relationship is probably not the most healthy thing for you
Psychologically speaking
We know that this is sometimes hard to control but wanting something that you can't have could potentially lead to some serious
Inner turmoil, it's cool to hang back and wait for an opening
But if you can't control your feelings, it could destroy your friendships and totally mess with your head
Two crushing on someone who's way too old or young for you
We know that age is just a number but there's definitely a limit to that
Crushing on someone who's way too older young for you could very well be an unhealthy thing
Hell it might not even be legal while these relationships can sometimes work out. They definitely don't stand the best chance of success
Again, this is often a case of desiring something you can't have and that can lead to some seriously unhealthy patterns
It's even more worrisome
if you find yourself crushing on older people who are married or if you are an older person crushing on someone who's still
Essentially a child there are tons of situations where older and younger people can make it work
But there's also a lot of potential for unhealthy behavior
three when a crush becomes an obsession
While it's true that devotion and obsession can sometimes be romantic
It's easy to cross the line into some very weird territory. If you find yourself following your crush
Creeping on their social media profiles and generally just worshipping them
Then you've probably developed some pretty unhealthy thought patterns
Not only is this unhealthy, but it also diminishes your chances of actually getting with your crush
It's better to just relax take it easy and try not to obsess too hard
Four when you develop a crush on someone who treats you poorly some of our viewers might disagree with some of these points
But everyone will understand that this is unhealthy and the sad part is it happens way too often
crushing on someone who treats you poorly is
Pretty unhealthy and it's something that definitely needs to be addressed
If you find yourself getting attracted to someone who is bullying you or putting you down
Maybe take a step back. This could be due to
Codependency or some sort of psychological trauma you need to work through with a professional
There is no reason why you should be attracted to someone who is abusive and mean
Sure bad boys can be attractive but someone who treats you badly will never make a good partner
six
Crushing on an ex. Well, it's obviously not something that we can control
It's generally not a positive thing in our lives in the simplest terms possible
Crushing on an ex means that you can't move on. Sure
There might be a chance of getting back together and it might be a great relationship when you do that
But what if your ex has moved on and you didn't what if you just find yourself wishing that you could get back together?
Even when you know that it's not possible
This goes back to the problem of desiring things
You can't have. An ex can be that forbidden fruit which torments you day and night
In the end it's better to just let go
While it's sometimes hard to do this being completely unable to is an unhealthy sign
Six crushing on someone in a long-distance relationship when you're not used to it. Let's be clear
long-distance relationships can work
We're not saying crushing on someone who lives far away is always unhealthy
But it definitely has potential to be it
Can be pretty stressful thinking about what that person is up to and whether or not they're getting romantic with other people. In
fact it can be pretty close to torture if you're used to long-distance relationships
you might be able to keep that crush alive and wait for your moment, but if not,
It could spiral into some pretty unhealthy thoughts and behaviors
Seven crushing on someone when you're already in a relationship
Crushing on when you're already in a relationship
Can be an uncontrollable thing and it's definitely a case of the grass always being greener on the other side
We know love just happens
It's not like we can control who we fall for or whether or not it happens when we're already in a relationship
But if you find yourself crushing on people while you're already tied down
It might just be a sign that you're not able to commit to a long-term partnership and you have problems being loyal
This is potentially a cause for alarm
especially if you're leading your partner on while not really interested in them all this can be is pretty unhealthy if
You enjoyed this video?
Please like and subscribe to see more content from Psych to go if you found out that your crush is actually healthy
We hope that it works out for you. Thanks so much for watching